how can I figure out who truly is my
best friend there's right and there's
wrong answers on this personality test
shoot your vlog on the gh 5 do you see
this do you see what's going on up here
oh my gosh I feel like this is the
closest to we get an exact science
a friendship anyone's ever gotten 20 19
right around the corner it's got me
thinking Nikko and myself have been
really good friends for twenty years
that even call my best friend but that
also got me thinking I've actually known
Jake for almost almost the same amount
of time we haven't we have been friends
for that amount of time necessarily but
we've known each other just as long and
I'm thinking well what if there's a way
how can I figure out who truly is my
best friend found a personality tests
online that I'm going to take and once I
have my results I'm gonna have Jake and
Nico do that same test as if it was me
answer whoever gets the closest results
to mine probably is my best friend right
[Music]
I am done to the test my results are
solid it's not just who we all guess
it's kind of similar it's like no like
there's right and there's wrong answers
on this personality test takes less than
12 minutes answer honestly as Sam you
find it difficult to introduce yourself
to other people
I'm gonna go middle agree on that one
Sam's very awkward with new people you
often get so lost in thoughts that you
ignore or forget you're surprised
strongly agree Niko it is now your turn
well me go get the same results that I
did hopefully myself well just you know
know yeah having done a ton of stuff
with him these are all experiences
together winning a debate matters less
to you than making sure no one gets
upset middle disagree if not strongly
disagree people can really upset him
yeah I've said it once in a while but
that's that's the way that he feels to
me I'd be like yeah he needs to justify
himself cuz I don't know what he's doing
you know Sam always does a ton of
planning versus adapt to it yeah sure
truthfully answering it past Sam yeah
how would Sam answer this if I was a man
I'd say neutral
just knowing Sam he probably answers to
the ends of the spectrum Peter he's like
full agree or whole disagrees not
relating between guy being able to
develop a plan and stick to it is the
most important part of every project mo
disagree yeah I'm confident about that I
think I know the guy you're trying to
instill doubt in my mind it's not gonna
work Carmichael you're not gonna trick
me on this one I know my buddy I know my
friend we are going to New York City we
are going to be going there to film a
broadcast commercial for battlefield 5
it's hard to rank what I'm most excited
for when it comes to going to New York
we're gonna be going to be an angel I've
never been there I heard it's cool it's
the mecca for anyone who's the filmmaker
or into cameras doesn't mean to enjoy
something on the cutting edge just when
you sit back and you go man I'm really
really appreciating the fact that this
was not possible to now watch it be
iterated to the next version phones
entertainment apps for Sam its lights
one thing in particular has caught my
eye for the last month or so the bigger
brother cuz he's really cool
luckily RGB lights having these
color-changing abilities on set it's
been a dream to shoot no gels no nothing
just you picked the color and you start
rolling this is the cutting edge in
lights the bigger version of these
lights called the timpani I don't know
how well they've been selling I don't
know if they've them in stock or
whatever I'm not sure what the plan is
all I know is that they are over at B&H
we're just gonna swing by it to at least
take a look at them
[Music]
yeah and I just put it in the wrong way
and also there was a line
we're here for a couple reasons number
one we're here to do a commercial spot
which we'll talk about in another video
we're also here because B and H invited
us out and they said hey guys come on by
our headquarters bring your GH five
shoot your vlog on the GH five and come
get some gear while you're here I'm
actually super super excited I've never
been to the actual vnh store do you see
this do you see what's going on up here
oh my gosh I feel like this is the
closest to we get an exact science
a friendship anyone's ever gotten you're
a logician no Josh what does that even
mean is this what he got this is this
what he got the audition personality
type is fairly rare that's true Sam's a
rare breed logicians pride themselves on
their inventiveness and creativity their
unique perspective and vigorous
intellect I'd say I'd say I nailed it
alright done Sam as a commander it's
kind of balancing extroverted
introverted he's natural one leader by
the gifts of charisma and confidence he
projects Authority characterized a
ruthless level of rationality using the
drive determination and sharp Minds
achieve but ever end they said to
themselves
sounds like Sam happiness lies in the
joy of achievement yeah
that's suddenly Sam
I have a good feeling about this you got
a different type entirely
Sam what you do what's your personality
my am a
so these is the Indies style bard
character here that that's me
apparently enthusiastic creative and
social will free spirit who always find
a reason to smile so what are your stats
what are your stats you know your stats
alright my my mind energy is that 63%
extroverted my energy energy is 87%
intuitive eighty-eight oh my nature
energy is 57 percent feeling at 68
percent too much too much thinking
energy my tactics are 57% costs acting
and 69% judgemental and then my identity
is 69% turbulence I had 60% to Ariana
now far more turbulent 64% introverted
exactly opposite of what Sam scored he
said 63% extroverted intuitive 71% vs.
87% for Sam thinking 57% versus feeling
I was the exact opposite victim slider
Jake are you feeling that I think I
think ego is and always will be soon as
the best friend I really was hoping for
better results this time man digging it
was like you need to find yourself a new
best friend okay here's the thing do you
answer this as one do you answer this as
the way that you think you are or as the
way that I think you are I guess the way
you gain it is by trying to think a
level deeper what's really going on in
that confident handsome young man's head
I'm gonna go back and read up on this
campaign or type so I didn't know yet
I'm a true free spirit yeah they're
often the life of the party
now I'm not the life of the party
I think I miss filled miss filled it out
mistakenly do you make to-do lists I
make to-do lists and today on my to-do
list but let's take a look at what's fun
right to-do list make a second revision
for a book we're working in appliance
for two battlegrounds videos that we
might be doing this fall
another outline for another original
video ideas secret one an outline for a
Dark Souls video subscripting that out
and also another script for a loop box
Christmas themed video so I got a lot of
writing on my plate to do each time I go
into this phase where I've gotten get
all this creative stuff on paper on page
we got to find a way to kind of inspire
myself but also I have to figure out a
way to do that in a way that I like to
do this is by watching and learning from
other people seeing how other people do
it it definitely inspires me seeing
successful people explain how they found
their success in whatever craft that is
it's very inspiring might be vdy some of
you feel like there's out there or
watching our channel seeing how we
approach things and maybe seeing how
that applies to your work great segue
here I wanted to thank Skillshare for
sponsoring today's video it's an online
learning community with thousands of
teachers and classes all at your
disposal a Premium Membership on
Skillshare gives you access to
high-quality classes from experts in
their field allowing you to improve the
work and craft that you love today I'm
checking out story writing fundamentals
by Daniel Jose older a New York Times
bestselling author he's done a lot of
successful works it's very inspiring to
me I love watching how he does what he
does so I can get better at what I do
looks like it's like you have to figure
out what you want to write before you
sit down
the other crucial element in this you
don't want to sit down and go oh I'm
gonna write something today you sit
there and just just write just write
whatever was in your head don't hold
back even if you think it was dumb or
maybe a dumb idea and you're trying to
write it just get it out there revision
two is for dealing with those dumb
things that I've got some skills your
classes to catch up on and hopefully
this helps improve my own process he'll
share also happens to be one of the most
affordable learning platforms out there
with an annual subscription it's less
than ten bucks a month at least the
Skillshare are in the description below
and the first 500 people to use this
link will get two months of premium for
free free don't have the sense of that
one I'm actually super super excited
I've never been to the actual vnh store
if I know everything about this is they
have the little slides where they ship
the gear on the store
from a different Department like yeah
let me let me hook that up for you I
don't have somebody running across the
store whether they have all these little
mechanized ramps
do you see this we see what's going on
up here it's like it's like the more
effective version of those like model
trains that's you see in certain stores
actually transport a useful thing
binocular since okay there's one very
specific item that we came here to check
out
these things are so no get me wrong I
love the aperture lights they're super
awesome super high quality and they're
coming out with their own color-changing
versions but in the mean time Clovis
Lucas
this order and then I also got you guys
the terrordome this is actually one of
our first samples for this new buxley
case we're coming out with this is gonna
hold three of them power supplies
accessories locking rings also has our
new firmware so you're gonna be able to
connect it directly to another unit this
can shadow another one this also
includes the effects
explosions magic explosions I know you
guys so now you can set a custom huge
iteration your explosions also one thing
we discovered when you're playing around
with it we have a paparazzi mode on here
you turn it all the way down to 2,800
watch your eyes everybody it could be a
little bit of gunfire in the background
yeah yes that's really cool yeah it's
cool yeah the best gear is the gear that
helps you achieve your vision and the
quickest most direct way possible and
this is definitely one of those products
it's an essential part of our on set
whatever what a repertoire yeah is an
essential part of our rapid no ya
repertoire hold on its repertoire
physical items or is it
consider some scrap eager channel if you
haven't already because we are about to
go shoot commercial for panel feels like
a really big deal for us you want to see
how that goes check out that story see
if you succeed or fail check out the
next video subscribe there's always a
benchmark of a really good collaborative
relationship is when you know exactly
what the other person means that other
person is exactly what you mean
[Music]